any visitor who chooses to take a cruise
on the river thames is bound to notice
the tower of london which rises
prominently in the eastern end of the
capital
constructed in the 11th century it has
served as a fortress a royal residence a
mint an armory a military garrison a zoo
and perhaps most significantly as a
prison
through it all its most important
function has been as a potent and
tangible symbol of royal authority
precisely because the tower represented
the power of kings and queens it was
frequently used over the long course of
its history
to make a statement about the nature of
royal authority sometimes through simple
decorative choices
for instance in the 14th century
elaborate wall paintings depicting
christian imagery were added to one of
the smaller towers in the complex
uncovered during a construction project
in 1953
they remind us of the inextricable links
that existed between religion and the
monarchy
even though today's church of england
established during the reign of henry
viii did not come into being until the
16th century
other stories are told by the walls of
the tower
graffiti carved into them reminds us of
those who were imprisoned there for
crimes against the state
one example inside the relatively small
beecham tower
is a carving depicting a falcon inside a
heraldic badge
it's thought to be a reference to anne
boleyn
henry viii's second wife whom he married
in 1533
following england's break with the pope
and the roman catholic church
anne upon her marriage to henry was
granted a royal badge with symbols of
the tudor dynasty a falcon and some
roses
but it was no ordinary falcon
to mark anne's queenly status the falcon
on this badge wore a crown and held a
scepter both symbols of royal authority
the carving of the falcon in the tower
bears none of these royal symbols though
their absence may reflect anne's fate as
she was executed in the tower only three
short years after marrying the king
the absence of royal references in the
tower carving of the falcon
means that it was likely the handiwork
of either a supporter of anne or someone
who was imprisoned with her when she was
confined to the tower in 1536
you see
during her short marriage to the king
and had failed to produce a male heir
and while this was serious enough
anne was also dealing with some other
problems
henry had a roaming eye and he was
frequently on the lookout for other
women
perhaps more ominous henry was
surrounded by courtiers who disliked
anne intensely
there were other factors as work as well
in particular there was a belief that
anne's last pregnancy which had ended in
the miscarriage of a deformed male fetus
was a sign of sexual sin
taken together
this evidence such as it was
contributed to ann's inglorious fall
from grace
by april 1536 she was investigated by
several different arms of the state
henry's close advisor thomas cromwell
accused her of rank and common behavior
she was arrested and confined to the
royal apartments in the tower where
she'd stayed on the eve of her
coronation
likely in the very same rooms where her
daughter the future elizabeth the first
would be confined in the 1550s
after a brief trial witnessed by several
thousand on the tower grounds
and was found guilty of having committed
adultery allegedly with four men
incest with her brother george the
viscount roshford
and conspiring against the king
she was sentenced to death by
decapitation
the executioner was a french swordsman
commissioned especially for the occasion
the solemn event occurred before a large
crowd on the tower green
the story of the tower is long and
complex
reaching back almost 500 years before
anne was beheaded and reaching forward
nearly another 500 to the present day
as an important structure in the history
of the city it was the site of many
notorious events
let's probe that history a bit more
deeply
in 1066
england was invaded by the forces of
william of normandy
a french noble with designs on the
english crown who has come to be known
usually as william the conqueror
william had likely been promised the
throne by his cousin edward the
confessor during a visit to england from
the continent in 1051.
as an invader william was successful
but he would face difficulties as he
tried to assert his power over the
entrenched saxon nobles and the merchant
classes who dominated london
among other things he faced a rebellious
populace who questioned the very
validity of his rule
londoners stood to lose much should the
semi-autonomous status of the city be
compromised
so
recognizing that he needed londoners on
his side william issued a charter that
secured their property rights and
offered them his protection
such a promise was especially important
in a country that had been subjected to
invasions for more than a thousand years
william knew however that agreements and
charters were not enough
so as he attempted to solidify his rule
he began to erect what were referred to
as strongholds
fortresses intended to guard against the
fickleness of london's fierce population
among the most significant was the
central structure at the heart of the
current tower complex
known as the white tower because of the
whitewash it received in the 1240s
during the reign of henry iii
it was made of stone from cannes in
northwestern france
a material reality this choice in
construction materials served as a
potent reminder that england was now
ruled by a foreign leader who possessed
imposing authority
situated at a high point overlooking the
river the tower complex rose some 90
feet into the air and had walls that
were 15 feet thick
it was protected by an old roman wall on
two sides and by ditches on the others
such an edifice so the thinking went
would help william consolidate his power
and protect himself
other structures were built in the west
of the city as well mostly to house
troops
and to ensure that londoners knew who
was boss
many developments in the tower complex
ensued in the centuries to come
in 1140 king stephen began to use the
tower as a royal residence adding heft
to its symbolic role
the literal seat of power it served
alongside the palace of westminster as a
space where the king's glory was on
display
in the 12th and 13th centuries
structures surrounding the white tower
increased in scope and their functions
grew in reach
and in import
the tower's most infamous function as a
prison began in 1100
upon his death in 1087 william the
conqueror was succeeded by his son
william rufus who reigned as william ii
until eleven hundred
during his time on the throne
a man named rainoff flambard was his
chaplain and chief minister
he was also engaged in financial
practices that some at least deemed
questionable
as a result when william rufus was
succeeded by his brother henry the first
flambard fell out of favor and was
subjected to legal prosecution
he was arrested for his machinations and
imprisoned in the tower
he remained there for six months but was
able to escape in february 1101
the story goes that a rope was smuggled
into his rooms in a flagon of wine
flambard offered the wine to his guards
who drank until they passed out he then
used the rope to exit the tower making
his way across the english channel to
seek refuge in
normandy after a period of exile
flambard was eventually welcomed back
and named bishop of durham in northern
england
despite this tarnish
the tower remained a place of reckoning
for prominent crimes and criminals into
the 20th century dur when during this
two world wars spies were in fact
executed on the grounds
and the nazi official rudolph hess who
came to britain in 1941 to privately
negotiate an end of the second world war
was imprisoned there
for a brief period
other developments occurred in the 500
years or so following william the
conqueror's arrival in england
two medieval kings henry iii who reigned
from 1216 to 1272 and edward the first
who reigned from 1272 until 1307 both
expanded the fortifications of the tower
complex henry iii did so
because he had to contend with regular
revolts by the barons the great
landowners of england
edward went further
having a protective moat dug in the
1270s though it was a body of frequently
stagnant and smelly water that remained
in place until 1843
it was during henry iii's reign that the
tower also became home to a zoo
the holy roman emperor for one gave
henry three leopards or lions it's a bit
unclear which as a gift
the king of norway gave him a polar bear
and in 1255 he acquired an elephant
these form the basis of a royal zoo that
remained a feature of tower life until
the 19th century
the tower also functioned as the royal
mint a storehouse for official records
and a secure place to keep royal regalia
and jewels
while images of the tower prior to 1500
are quite rare
we get a glimpse of it albeit in highly
stylized fashion
and its symbolic role
in an illustrated volume of the duke of
orleans poetry commissioned by king
edward iv in the late 15th century
in this hand-colored depiction
the complexes roll as military garrison
and seat of royal power are showcased
amid a parade of troops royal figures
are shown clad in irman and the personal
flag of the monarch flies over the
turrets of the whitewashed structure
this symbolism
was also readily on display
when elizabeth the first came to the
throne following the death of her
half-sister mary in 1558
eleven days after she was proclaimed
queen like other monarchs before her she
ceremoniously took possession of the
tower the very place of her mother's
execution
possession was a first step in the
ancient rituals of coronation
it symbolized the queen's control over
the mint
and the defense of the realm
it also served to remind londoners who
jealously guarded their autonomy
that the new monarch's authority
extended over them
on january 14 1559
the tower also marked the starting point
of elizabeth's coronation procession
city streets were decorated with silk
and tapestries and the queen processed
from it in a chariot accompanied by
lords and ladies in crimson velvet and
trumpeters wearing red gowns
as she made her way to london's urban
center she was met with sites to behold
everywhere
public performances were staged in
nearly every london neighborhood
residents paid homage to the new queen
by acting out skits singing songs of
praise and reading simple poems and
verse composed especially for the
occasion
because the tower was such a potent
symbol of power and authority it
periodically came under attack
from those who wished to air grievances
or achieve a particular political goal
for instance
in 1349
the country experienced an outbreak of
the bubonic plague otherwise known as
the black death which killed close to
half of london's population
approximately 70 000 people were said to
have died
periodic outbreaks of the illness
occurred through the 1360s
the economic dislocation wrought by the
worldwide pandemic led to extreme
measures
including limits on wages and new taxes
not surprisingly this produced
widespread discontent
in
1377 king richard ii came to the throne
at the age of 10.
his policies were guided by his uncle
john of gaunt who administered a
despised poll tax on all english people
over the age of 15.
widespread resistance to paying led to
the creation of royal commissions to
investigate how extensive tax evasion
was
and to extract payments from the
holdouts
in may 1381
a commission set out for the county of
essex just northeast of london
it was met by a series of uprisings led
by the priest john ball and a humble
artisan named watt tyler that came to be
known as the peasants revolt
ball had acquired a reputation as a
proponent of radical ideas questioning
the very notion of a feudal hierarchy
he also wondered aloud why if all
descended from adam and eve there should
be distinctions of rank
emboldened by such critiques and fueled
by economic and social discontent the
frustrated peasantry considered its
options
in mid-june 1381
some sixty thousand armed peasants
converged upon black heath to the south
and the east of the tower of london
their request to meet with the king as
part of their demands for greater social
equality were refused
so
they marched directly into london proper
along the way
they destroyed the homes of the great
and the wealthy and they released the
inmates of marshall c prison in
southwark
the symbolic gestures of attacking signs
of privilege continued for several days
among the grandest targets was john of
gaunt's london residence the savoy
there the peasants killed john's
servants tore gold and silver cloth to
pieces crushed his jewels destroyed his
tapestries and threw countless numbers
of his possessions into the river
they also lit an enormous bonfire
fueled by gunpowder reducing the palace
to ruins
turning back to the king
the crowd returned to the tower and
camped outside its gates richard ii
recognizing that he needed to do
something agreed to meet the peasants in
mile end to the east of the city
while he was there supposedly granting
concessions
another group broke into the tower
destroying kitchens bed chambers halls
and armories they even ransacked the
king's mother's apartments destroying
furniture and tearing her bed clothes to
shreds
most significantly the unhappy peasants
entered the white tower where four
members of the king's government
including the archbishop of canterbury
and the king's treasurer were dragged
out of the chapel and beheaded
their heads were placed on pikes and
paraded through the city
the revolt largely ended the next day
watt tyler was stabbed to death by the
mayor of london
and the king's supporters were able to
defuse the crowd
the revolt's leaders were ultimately
executed and many of the king's promises
of economic and social reform when
unrealized
but the burden of the poll tax was
eliminated for ordinary englishmen and
women
let's now look at a totally different
kind of challenge to the tower's
symbolic stature this time in the 17th
century
in the decades before the english civil
war from 1642 to 1651
the election of the lord mayor for the
city of london was frequently
accompanied by a street performance
known as the lord mayor's show
the show's mixed theatrical performances
with dance music speeches and firework
displays
and they were scripted by playwrights
one of these playwrights was thomas
haywood
who wrote seven of the shows between
1631
and 1639
many of the presentations offered some
praise of the monarch
but they also sought to highlight the
power of the lord mayor and the
political autonomy of the city of london
in some cases
haywood's shows
challenged what has been referred to as
the royal ideology of the tower of
london
this signaled growing tension between
the king at the time charles the first
and others who thought that royal
authority might be getting just a bit
out of hand
in the 1635 show london's harbor of
health and happiness
the tower is depicted
not as a symbol of royal splendor but
rather as a site of royal tyranny where
people have been imprisoned unfairly
the most notable example of this was
richard the duke of gloucester who in
1483
had become the protector of his brother
edward iv 12 year old royal son edward v
hungry for power richard imprisoned the
young king and his brother in the tower
and allegedly had them murdered before
being proclaimed king himself
in 1638 the show the port or harbor of
piety referred to the tower as a space
where the monarch imprisoned religious
dissenters
most notably during the 16th century
when the battle between protestants and
catholics raged
haywood's representations of the virgin
mary revealed the author's support for
catholics and served as a reminder of
the tower's history in persecuting and
torturing roman catholics during the
reigns of edward vi
from 1547
until 1553 and elizabeth the first from
1558 until 1603
the tower faced other affronts during
the 19th century
including age fire
and stench
by the time queen victoria came to the
throne in 1837
years of wear and tear on the tower
meant that it like any ancient structure
was in need of repair
the first duke of wellington arthur
wellesley was the man who oversaw many
of these needed improvements
wellington was best known as the
military leader who defeated napoleon
bonaparte at the battle of waterloo
in recognition of his service
he was made constable of the tower of
london a sinicure
that came with a sizeable annual income
most beneficiaries of this office
treated it as a preferment
wellington took it seriously rooting out
corruption and ensuring that the tower
was an appropriate symbol of the nation
among the reforms he implemented at the
tower
was an attempt to professionalize the
royal household guards the yeoman waters
or beefeaters
created in the middle ages they were by
the 19th century essentially
unscrupulous tour guides extorting money
from visitors and using the autonomy of
the tower precinct to avoid paying their
debts
wellington changed this
by appointing ex-military men of good
character to represent the queen and the
nation effectively
changes to the tower were also prompted
by two specific developments
a massive fire in the middle of the 19th
century and the recognition that the
stagnant water in the tower's moat was
becoming a major nuisance and a major
health hazard
let's turn first to the fire
on the evening of october 30th 1841
a chimney fire in the complex quickly
spread
the towers fire engines and water supply
were inadequate to combat the threat
as the evening wore on the flames
engulfed the armory storehouse and
threatened the martin tower where the
crown jewels were stored the most
valuables were in fact safe
newspapers described the blaze as a
truly national calamity that exceeded
and grandeur even the great fire of the
house of commons which had occurred in
1834
plans guided by the government and the
monarch were laid to rebuild some
structures to rationalize others and
ultimately to plan for the future
foremost among wellington's initiatives
was a plan to replace the complex's 17th
century brick and stone storehouse now
completely destroyed with a new more
commodious barracks for the soldiers who
resided in the tower complex
known as the waterloo barracks in honor
of his military victory against napoleon
bonaparte the living quarters were
completed in 1845.
wellington also closed the pubs that had
previously been open in the tower
replacing them with proper facilities
for feeding soldiers and thereby
allowing officers to socialize in a
class segregated mess
around the same time wellington
undertook to drain the tower moat
rather than being cleansed by the river
thames the moat retained the human waste
the tower's residents emptied into it on
a daily basis
it was a breeding ground for waterborne
disease
and unbefitting a historic landmark
thanks to wellington's efforts the moat
was delivered from putrid animal and
excrementitious
matter
in the words of one contemporary and
replaced with dry land that extended the
tower's grounds creating space for
military drills and other activities
but the tower was a target of
desecration as well as beautification
those who supported either irish
independence in the 19th century or the
unification of the northern and southern
counties of ireland in the 20th struck
on several different occasions
during the 19th century many in ireland
began to question british domination and
called for home rule
among those who embraced a more radical
approach the quest for
self-determination justified acts of
violence
in 1885 activists seeking to establish
an independent irish republic were
concluding a four-year campaign of
bombing that included the tower of
london as a predominantly symbolic
target
part of the dynamite war a bomb was
detonated in the white tower on january
24 1885
at around the same time as bombs were
also exploding in parliament
at the tower complex windows and walls
were blown out and a large-scale fire
that the tower fire brigade contained
erupted
but this was not of course the final
time the tower came under attack by
irish nationalists
in 1922
britain granted independence to the
southern portion of ireland while six
northern counties with a majority
protestant population remained a part of
the united kingdom
this accommodation stoked outrage among
more militant activists in the irish
independence movement
in 1969
after several decades of relative quiet
the paramilitary organization the irish
republican army responded to perceived
injustices and the protestant
persecution of catholics by inaugurating
a further campaign of violence
this campaign was most associated with
two pub bombings in the english cities
of birmingham and guilford in 1974.
hundreds were injured and more than two
dozen were killed
there was also another attack on the
tower of london that same year this one
widely attributed to the ira but not
claimed by it
by this time the tower was no longer a
royal residence nor was it a center of
government
but it remained a symbol of british
authority as well as an important
tourist destination and so
it remained a potentially value-rich
target for terrorist acts
at around two in the afternoon on july
17
1974 at least one bomb exploded in the
white tower it was thought to have been
placed under the royal george cannon in
one of the public exhibition spaces
the cannon was blown off its base
multiple suits of metal armor were
destroyed and wood and other debris flew
through the air
41 people were injured and one 47 year
old woman was killed
a librarian named dorothy household
some of the injuries were actually quite
severe a six-year-old boy from new
zealand lost his leg in the blast
debate in the house of commons on the
night of the explosion revealed just how
raw emotions were
some members rose to offer condolences
and expressed concern that londoners and
tourists alike were vulnerable to
terrorist acts
others such as mp william malloy stated
defiantly that attacks on symbolic
structures such as the tower would not
bend the will of the people
precisely because the tower is so rich
in history and symbolic in meaning it
can elicit very strong reactions as i
walked the grounds and climbed one of
the many flights of stairs during a
recent visit i couldn't help but think
about the many who have lived and died
sometimes quite notoriously
within the towers carefully manicured
precincts
contained within the complex are stories
of the rich and the poor the fortunate
and the unfortunate and the damned and
the saved